[Music]
I think it's terrible you want another
truth I think it's a disgrace what's
going on in this country I think it's a
disgrace the memo was sent to Congress
it was Declassified Congress will do
whatever they're going to do but I think
it's a disgrace what's happening in our
country the president earlier today
reacting to the stunning FISA memo which
was in fact he classified joining us now
with reaction North Carolina congressman
chairman of the house freedom caucus
mark meadows Ohio congressman also
freedom caucus member Jim Jordan
congressman meadows let's start with you
I was wondering at times if people were
over selling this and in many ways they
think you undersold it in this respect I
think this is the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal we've ever had where
you have one presidential candidate
using phony Russian propaganda bought
and paid for and then you have the
highest-ranking people in the DOJ in in
the FBI using the powerful tools of
intelligence to try and spy on and
successfully spy on and help hopefully
derail an opposition party candidate and
then undermining an incoming president
we've never seen this before
congressman well we haven't Sean and
you've been covering this for for many
many months in fact when everybody was
criticizing you about what you believed
to be going on today we now know that
indeed it was going on and Sean I can
tell you probably the thing that that
concerns me the most is that this is the
tip of the iceberg we're already looking
and reviewing other documents and other
sources of information that would end to
indicate other parts of collusion and
you know I can tell you there was no
Russian collusion between this president
and the Russians but now what we're
seeing is collusion actually did take
place but it was from the Hillary
Clinton campaign and and really trying
to affect the the election through this
dossier that they paid for and was used
to spy on American US citizens
congressman Jordan I I watched you in
committees and there were times I'm well
finally somebody saying it I felt like I
was hanging out
a thread by my by myself some nights
with with some of my good partners and
friends on the show but it is worse than
we thought
I'm told that we might have a Grassley
memo as early as next week that takes it
yet to another level remember what we
learned today Sean not once not twice
not three times but four times the top
people the FBI took this salacious and
unverified document this dossier to the
secret court to get a secret warrant to
spy on a fellow American and guess why
they never told the court that the
Democratic National Committee that
Clinton campaign paid for it for
opportunities that tell the truth to the
court and they didn't do it to spy on a
fellow citizen and they did that in the
context of a presidential campaign with
me as Marcus said this should never
happen in this great country it never
should so so congressman meadows what
does this mean I would argue without all
of this what we are describing and
talking about tonight there is no
special counsel Muller and I'm saying he
needs to go yesterday because he never
should have been appointed based on what
we know tonight well what we do know is
much of the information that actually
called for a special prosecutor was
tainted and when we see that you know
you have to look at the fruit of a
tainted investigation and and it's very
troubling I I believe that Special
Counsel Mueller will come back and show
that this president didn't collude with
the Russians but I think the underlying
problem is is there was a whole lot Jim
was just talking about it you know four
times they went to a FISA Court to spy
on American citizens but three of those
times they did so after knowing that the
very person who wrote the dossier was
not telling the truth who is Hillary's
in the beginning and they never taken
the court without a doubt omission that
that omission is a lie all right
congressman Jordan what should happen
next what's the next step in terms of we
want to write this tremendous injustice
and constitutional violation the thing
mark and I and several other members
called for six months ago a second
special counsel we know Muller can't
expand his probe he's inherently
compromised on this
we know Jeff session has recused himself
the
only remedy and I wish this wasn't the
case I don't big fan of special counsels
but I see no other remedy than a second
special counsel and I'd add one thing
make sure they're not from the swamp
make sure it's some retired federal
judge from Iowa or Oklahoma or somewhere
pick someone who come in and look at
this entire situation so the American
people can once again have confidence in
the top people running these important
agencies in our government biggest abuse
of power corruption case in our history
thank you both for what you have done
you to help ease this